[Musique]
elles sont rouges blanches roses ou
encore jaunes les plantes et guayes tous
les ans nos paysages de printemps à
Montfort-l'Amaury la 11e édition de la
fête des plantes et des jardins a battu
son plan ce weekend une cinquantaine
d'exposants ont répondu à l'appel
l'occasion de rappeler au jardinier
chevronné ou au simple curieux les
consignes pour un beau jardin en cette
saison lui donner de l'amour et un peu
d'eau au printemps on s'occupe déjà de
tout désherber d'enlever le paillage
d'hiver pour histoire qu'on est protégé
nos plantes on commence à préparer la
terre pour le potager on retourne la
terre on peut planter le persil les
fraisiers tous les petits fruits cassis
groseilles
framboise vous pouvez semer des petits
pois attention tout de même à bien
protéger les plantes d'après la croyance
populaire il vaut mieux planter après
les saints de glace qui ont lieu mi-mai
cette période redoutée des jardiniers
correspond au retour du gel malgré le
redout printanier pour tout ce qui est
plant annuel les saints glaces ça peut
être très
fragile et mourir sur le coup pour un
petit coup de gelé quoi on peut
commencer à planter maintenant pour ce
qui est arbuste des choses qui sont
assez résistantes qui ont grandi dans
des gros godets pour ce qui est au
potager ou les petites fleurs style les
géraniums les petites pétunias tout ça
on vaut mieux attendre fin avril début
mai un événement qui permet aussi de
découvrir les bons plans locaux et
écologiques pour son jardin
je cultive des plans de légumes des
aromatiques des plantes médicinales des
fleurs comestibles tout ça en
agriculture biologique donc je suis
certifiée j'utilise de l'eau de pluie
pour l'irrigation je n'utilise pas de
chauffage
à part pour faire germer les semis j'ai
une technique particulière je travaille
en mode donc c'est une technique qui
n'utilise pas d'emballage puisque je
presse des mottes avec une machine
spéciale j'utilise une fourche qui donne
des petites mottes comme ça de terre
tulipes géranium ou bien forsythia
inutile d'avoir la main verte pour s'y
mettre binette et arrosoir n'attendent
que vous